so no developer there's no tell us about
constructions of pepper tree thank you
hi I will talk about a high-dimensional
which are a high dimensional simplicial
complex analog spanning tree and this is
a joint work with naughty zinnia so let
me start by recording some of the of the
equivalent definition of of spanning
trees and then we'll see how do we want
to to generalize them to higher to
higher dimensions and ask all sort of a
questions about them so one way to
define as to define s s s penalty if I
think that it is a connected and a
cyclic
and and this also has like an algebra
called one can say ho ho ho ho logical
or perhaps in this in this conference
one should say a Metroid point of view
which is the following - as in the
simplest way one can look on I am a a
matrix that we call that we call the
boundary matrix operator it is an N by n
choose 2 well n is the number of
vertices and in the I I J column we with
one a minus one in the in the eyes and
and J is Co Co Co Co Co Co coordinate to
to express the fact that to the boundary
of the edge I J is like the vertex I -
the very XJ for instance and then we say
that X penalty is just a is just a basis
of the column space of Delta
and then things isn't know that
connectivity is in equivalence of and of
the fact that of of the fact that the
basis is spanning and being a cyclic
equivalent to to be to independence and
the third that one definition that the
second definition the third one which
one can consider it is that s s s
penalty is there is a collapsible graph
bye-bye bye-bye
collapsible I mean that that it can be
collapsed to a point by a sequence of
elementary collapses so here like the
constants we can take this to me and we
choose one a leaf and its edge and
remove it so this is a what is called an
elementary collapse and what it means is
here to move we move
and so we will stay with this guy in the
routine and and we can perform a
sequence of elementary collapses until
we get to a point that's like that
another definition and and I want to
first talk about how these definitions
will will generalize to a higher
dimension so this starts and in a book
of a line a83 the busy he is fixin the
number of vertices n and the the the the
and the dimension D and then and writing
the two oh one can can can have in mind
d equals 2 for most of these doctrines
and he looked on the d dimensional
boundary operator so this would be the
one-dimensional from from one
dimensional object to zero and I for
instance the a the two dimensional in
very negative and just do rosin and n2
three columns and in the I J cake in the
ijk column you have the a you have a
vector representing the the the the the
the boundary of them of a rj k so so you
so you'll have one in a journey let's
say if you have iCade and minus one to
fit the orientation and jacob one and a
and let's say that a I did a a so here's
a definition I did D dimensional hyper
tree is just a basis for this so this
linear retreat and and this the day the
definition so here's one example
so the the the the simplest example of a
a hyper thing is the d-dimensional
style will you take Y to be all the
phases
that contained some vertex let's say one
so so like for instance if we look at N
equals 4 and D equals 2
we'll have let's say we put 1 in the
middle so start with all these and we
would end with n vertices and all the
edges and then we simply choose all the
vertices
all the faces of all the the
two-dimensional faces that contain 1 so
it has this guy that guy this one and
one can one can one can check that the
that these faces are indeed a ye a basis
for this for this way to enhance why is
is a hyper tree and as a conclusion that
is the rank of this matrix all of this
Madrid is an minus 1 choose this is and
we will need this and there is an A and
an additional observation I would like
to make is that this mr. is is also a
a collapsible complex and in the sense
and did I want can so let us draw some
collapse so it's a a one can collapse
all the faces towards one so we can
first lose this this agent face dislike
squash it remained this thing and so
forth until we get to a point and a
simple observation if that any maybe
budget today so in a simple observation
is that every collapsible complex in
this sense that that has a full skeleton
is also a ad dimensional hybrid we saw
in in the equals 1 if the equals 1 then
the the the notions are in fact a
revelant now maybe I should state that
the the main theorem of collage paper so
in a very nice theorem and they and I
should have mentioned before Mabel
Maternity before as a so this is assumed
by Allah and they said that if you take
the sum of all the the n-dimensional the
end vertex D dimensional a a a hyper T
so this is the end vertex the hypotenuse
some over the size of and I will I will
act I will explain what what this is but
some of the size of the integral
whoo-hoo-hoo mala DS squared then you
get 10 to the power of n minus 2 choose
D and and and this should be a compared
of course with the famous Cadiz formula
that that says that the number of an
vertex is n to the power n minus 2 so so
so this is a very nice nice
generalization of a telus formula and
and I just need to to maybe explain what
is the the Salmond here so for those
[Music]
so and what is this oh this is this is a
basically like the the like the the like
the the partition function of a of a
determinantal process so want me to see
this number just so you take the matrix
it's a it's a it's a sub matrix of delta
whose columns correspond to tea and and
the rows are are are are all the all the
the -1 phases that the that do not
contain one and you take the determinant
of this matrix causing a absolute value
so ii i the process and it's very nice
formula and and the poof i'm not go
through it buddy it is like a a
counterpart of the matrix three other
part of
on the matrix teeth you still apply to
any higher ground
yes so so so this can be this can be
extended so so you can have a have a
formula of the form T in the hyper trees
that it's a GT is in some Y of the same
thing school and and this should be
equal to one over some a concert which a
which I think should be n to the N minus
each may be an n minus 2 choose the
manifold but I'm not sure about that but
times the product of the of of lambda I
words will live and I are the
eigenvalues of wise discrete notion and
and this will accent what is known as a
kickoffs kickoff
a formula
okay good so we are actually well we are
interested in a in a in a in a more
combinatorial set of questions oh no no
it's not the only one exactly so so a so
I'll get to that so so so so so here are
some some some questions so first
question is okay so so so we we do have
this this formula but what about simply
the size the the the the the number of
of n vertex D hi birthdays so that one
question the second question is what
does a random a uniformly random tea in
a tea and the looks like
so for instance here
here are two conjectures and I can take
the boat of a deal - if if if he would
agree but I can say and so so first one
is that with high probability to take a
random tree T is not collapsible so this
goes to one is as n goes to in this is
little o as n goes to infinity and I and
and an even stronger conjecture is that
a condom - T if I look at the age of the
size of that is exponential in and to
the deep liquid so particular question
and so I used to also ask if if can we
have can we efficiently efficiently
generate a a condom a random a high
poetry but
[Music]
thanks to the booklet that we saw this
morning the answer is yes but I mean but
the the point that I think these these
days cone judges make is that is that is
that although we can efficiently
generate a a random a a random hybrid a
it is how to to to read it
it's typical properties of the the the
the the mark of J posts like
let me talk a little bit about I excuse
my had expected rid of the determinant
was not so square
yes not that I know up no I learned from
the question but I don't know I mean at
the moment that the the the the best
thing I can do is that and I and I have
some bounce bounce that I will show you
on the on the on the number of
hypotheses so what was known before our
work is that so one side is eighty Ness
is the fact that right you can always
take like a and choose rink that is the
basic thing that you can do and this is
roughly in and over the plus 1 to the n
choose D and a bound which is fairly so
it follows from follows from kalaiy
allies formula
I'm like n of D plus 1 to be present to
end
- selective and - montes didn't know
today and so so the question that that
that we service like can we improve this
this constant and and so so we had one
inductive confirm a interactive concept
reaction which I will show one can show
that the number event of a number of
number of of a number of collapsible and
vertex D D traded at least and over
something like e to the 1/2 plus 1 over
D and I will
so this in a second
maybe let me skip this because it's not
that hardened and mainly I would like to
talk about assurances that the number of
opportunities at least tau D times and
with the following properties so so so
first of all all these more than this
bound beat this bound for every D
greater than 2 and the second is that a
Tau D at 8:30 and and and
/ e over D plus one which goes to one as
Z goes to infinity so is our our our
bound in some in some very recent
approaches the upper bound now I would
like to say a few words
all this theorem
[Music]
so the main idea is to do a random
greedy algorithm which is like just a
basically just do rusticles algorithm so
we start with a with with with the empty
complex so with no d dimensional faces
at all so let's call this start with T 0
having noted no dot and then for in
every step I what we do is we choose we
choose that we add Sigma I that is
chosen a chosen chosen uniformly at
random from from all the set of faces
that ti9 Swan a eagerness 8 is still
independent still has no top top Knology
[Music]
so and let Koda set a so obvious better
to to look at when you want to sample a
a random basis of of a a of a Metroid
and the main thing is to find a good
good lower bound on the size of these
sets a set set a a I so so so we have to
the M partner in this lamb at the first
part is that with high probability so
every I let's say between 1 and 1 minus
epsilon D which is roughly looks like e
to the minus D over D plus 1 times and
micron to the so in in most steps with
high probability the the size of a is
very large it is almost all the possible
phaser
and the second part is like a wolf case
lemma which says that for every I the
size of AI is always wet and choose the
plus one times one minus I divided by n
minus 1 choose D so and and when you
[Music]
when you you combine these two bounds
you you you you he immediately get this
o this result and maybe I just want to
have a short short the monkey
that also with high probability with
this the the the the a high-protein diet
so the last one is a high poetry is not
collapsible like so this is like some
again we can evidence for for the
conjecture that we saw and and I still
have a couple of a minute so I want to
tell you about one more thing so another
constant construction that we talked
about was a so called one out a random
complex so so there's a very nice piece
of Kahless formula which is due to do to
to to julienne and it finds an N squared
to one map
form a functions fee from end to end to
spinning so that would prove it and and
I'm not going to get into the details of
this map but like the first part of the
map the first part is too so so so you
you have some a free from Edwin so you
build a what's called a one out one out
directed one out directed grass course X
points to see of X and so so so that the
first part you look the the the second
part is that you remove all the circles
remove all all the cycles in this graph
so let's call this graph Jaffe among all
the circles in in in in in in the field
and third part which is nice so you
somehow fix it fix it to be a treat and
the the nice
property of this proof is is that if
free is a if thing is a a random map
random then then if fees random then
with high probability the number of
cycles the events of the the number of
ends of edges that are deleted that are
deleted in the in this second part is
all the root n so it's like you almost
us so you almost don't a a changer your
your one out to get to a random tree and
as a as a as as a consequence you can
learn a lot about a random uniform
spanning trees from a random one out so
flat select for example
one can a so-so then you can learn about
random spinning spinning trees from a
random one out graph which are from
random one out of which are much simpler
objects select for I think you can you
can show that the number of leaf is
roughly and over a or you or you can
show that the diameter is of the root
and all sorts of things so so we asked a
certain I'll take only really two minute
would whether this one out consequence
reaction could be generalized to a to
hire to higher dimensions
so Allison tell about that so we talked
about the following random model where
we you and so you met that you work with
a value for D equals two just for the
sake of this talk so you let every edge
[Music]
Anjali select a random vertex let's call
it C of IJ and and and then you control
the D D random complex as not well it s
something which which contains for every
edge IJ faith I J and and the C IJ right
if you have some I J every faith chooses
a random complex and and what we show is
that is that we type with high
probability over a over D the random
selection see if I look on the boundary
matrix of which I will do I say the
edges n choose 2 and I Sophie then the
kernel of this guy is of dimension which
is a little o of n square so in
something like a able to to to recover
this
this theorem and we think that that that
if one is able to find some some good
bounce on the so particular good bounce
good upper bound for the permanent of
this matrix the determinant of this
matrix imply new lower bounds or the
number of trees and maybe didn't just
end here with we with one a open
question that is may be suitable for
this audience that is a is there an
efficient efficient efficient algorithm
to sample random collapsible trees
it very interesting to understand
[Applause]
this is a really stupid question but how
much does the definition of hyper treat
depend on us using the integers for the
homology groups
suppose so so integers or or or result
or version s will be the same but if you
do then some other a finite field
instead that the two give less arbitrate
accessibility support for the chemistry
of the responder so I think that like a
new adult or girl to buy a niacin and
some of his students that show that
random uniform spanning tree in den sex
expander has a diameter of so the case
of graphs
yes distributional span trees is closely
related to electrical flows are there
some flows you can define our complexes
which that's so where resistors tell you
the marginal progress so I mean one can
like follow formerly the the the
definitions but like for isn't this the
the this this synth little Metroid is
not a balanced so like there's no real
way that I found to use this for foreign
for a a sampling method
[Applause]
so